so we are telling young people if you
fail it's your fault and we are making
it impossible for them to succeed and I
think this is creating in many cases a
mental health crisis for young people so
I want to send a message out here to
young people especially on people from
poor or ordinary backgrounds okay
if you are feeling like you are poor and
other people around you are rich that is
not your fault
you have been given a system where it is
impossible for people born into poor
families to get rich so if you're not
happy about that
you need to come and help us change the
system you know that is what this
channel is here for if the system as it
is continues
people from poor families will never be
able to escape poverty this is not your
fault this is a system that makes it
possible for you
support us and help us change that
system